when a man idealizes a woman and
projects his animal onto her
he gives her tremendous power
why is it dangerous for a woman to
identify with that projection
or like meryl monroe to become the love
goddess and live out his desires
because as we know from the life history
of marilyn
monroe she she did not live her own life
she she acted all the time the animal of
men generally they are women and that is
ultimately due to the power drive
when women discover that if they are
beautiful they can exert a magic power
over men then they take to acting all
the time the animal
we are even in our jargon sometimes
talking about animal
women those are women who
find out how to act the animal to men
and because but because this is not love
but pure power drive it is destructive
to the men
and to themselves because it has
it it's using the guise of love
for worldly power
such women want to rule the men they
want to
the men to be all at their feet and then
they naturally are unhappy because they
don't feel loved
i remember when i was young
sometimes when a man projected his
animal onto me and was pursuing me and
giving me presents and so on
i had the distinct feeling but that
fellow doesn't know me at all he's
chasing an
image i wanted to look back who he who
is he
chasing it's not me me as a human being
he doesn't see
and so if a woman falls into the trap of
acting out the animal
she can exert a tremendous power over
men
but at the same time inwardly she's
frustrated
because those men love her image they
don't love her
so she's really very lonely underneath
and that's what caught up with poor
marilyn monroe
and does this woman who's playing the
anima does she just fulfill a man's
needs
anything he wants she does or how does
it work
it works as long as it is an adventure
or a love affair
then she fills out his needs but when he
has to live with her in every
if he marries her and has to live with
her in everyday life
then comes the trouble a she will play
the animal to all the other men as well
and he'll not like that and secondly
he'll
suddenly discover that underneath that
beautiful mask
there is no human being there's no
warmth there's no possibility of a human
relationship
so to marry an animal figure is most
disappointing
that these women who play that are
called by the french farm fratal
women who ruin men
if a man has this mother complex then
how does he experience women in real
life
if a man